how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU today we
are talking about spider-man 3 now
although we don't know too much about
spider-man 3 there are a few things that
we definitely do know one is that he's
going to be on the run as a wanted man
in spider-man 3 and 2 he's definitely
going to need somebody to help him both
with everybody that's going to be
chasing him as far as villains are
concerned and to help him illegally even
though Mysterio framed him and the whole
world thinks he's a murderer of course
we know that he's not so he's going to
need some help improving that he's
innocent and now it's looking like he
could be getting some legal assistance
and superhero assistance from Matt
Murdock
daredevil himself will break down all
the reports in this video if you're new
be sure to subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man 3 and
the MCU daredevil could quite possibly
be the one character that everybody
wants to cross over into the MCU from
the Netflix shows and the vast majority
of the fans have said that they would
really want Charlie Cox to continue to
play Matt Murdock well we now have
worried about when Marvel Studios and
Disney are going to be getting the
rights back to those Netflix characters
such as The Punisher Luke Cage iron fist
Jessica Jones and of course daredevil
but it appears that daredevil may be
just a little bit different from all of
the other characters the contract
between Marvel Studios and Netflix
states that Marvel Studios cannot use
the characters until two years after the
last episode that they appeared in on
their Netflix series and according to
this contract here are when the
characters are coming back to Marvel
Studios iron fist on October 12th of
2020 Luke Cage on October 19th of 2020
daredevil November 29th of 2020 the
Punisher February 18th 2021 and Jessica
Jones February 18th of 2021 as well so
they're coming home relatively soon
however there has been a report that
daredevil is actually already back at
Marvel Studios or will be coming back
sooner than expected
a few days ago Jeremy Conrad from MCU
cosmic reported that it sounds like
someone had an earlier homecoming than
expected posting a picture of daredevil
with it and then below in a thread said
no homecoming isn't a spider-man hint
just that the Guardian devil
come home earlier than people thought he
would with another gif of daredevil but
let's talk about why daredevil would be
the only character to come back sooner
than expected from it's Netflix contract
the only logical reason that Marvel
Studios would want to get a character
back sooner than they were supposed to
is so they could put him in a movie and
there is one specific character who
happens to need a lawyer which Matt
Murdock is and that is Peter Parker
not to mention spider-man will also need
some help from daredevil in fighting all
of the enemies that are going to be
coming after him especially since Kevin
Feige has stated that in this film
spider-man is really going to come into
his own and that he's going to be truly
alone he won't have any of his friends
or family that have helped him in the
past so that means he's going to need
some new help and daredevil truly is the
perfect fit daredevil and spider-man
have a very long relationship together
in the comics we also know that Marvel
Studios is going to begin to introduce
many new characters into the MCU via
movies and Disney plus we also know that
Kevin Feige is now C CEO of Marvel
Studios chief creative officer that
means he is now in charge of all of the
Marvel Studios television shows and
characters so Kevin Feige right now
according to this report from MCU cosmic
is in full control over daredevil and
the really interesting thing is is that
this news comes right around the time
that they announced when spider-man 3 is
going to be shooting and it's been
revealed that they're going to start on
July 13th this year and that leads us
back to the question why would Marvel
Studios want to get the rights to
daredevil back sooner than the end of
the year right now well it seems to
point to the fact that spider-man is
going to run into daredevil in
spider-man 3 the story seems to be set
up perfectly for it and now Marvel has
the rights back to use him and filming
starts in a few months so although
nothing is confirmed it does seem likely
that we could see daredevil in
spider-man 3 helping out Peter Parker so
let me know what you think about this
would you like to see daredevil in
spider-man 3 would you like Matt Murdock
to be the person to help out Peter
Parker let me know if you would or if
you have somebody else in mind let me
know in the comments down below as well
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe and notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU you can follow me on
Twitter for live updates and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof